an independent investigation has found
that the murder of shireen abu aklay by
israeli soldiers was deliberate the
probe was jointly carried out by
london-based forensic architecture and
al-haq a human rights group al jazeera
provided material for the analysis
the investigation reconstructed in this
video and animation studied the precise
angle of the israeli sniper location of
the journalist the rate of fire and the
number of bullets used it rules out any
possibility of confrontations between
israeli forces and palestinian gunmen in
the occupied west bank at the time of
shireen's killing it shows that the
sniper shot for two minutes deliberately
targeting the al jazeera journalist and
anyone who tried to rescue her shireen
was shot in the head by israeli forces
while on assignment in janine in may
iuf marksmen typically use an optical
scope that is mounted on their m4
assault rifles and magnifies their
vision four times
this is the opening for the scope we
simulated how shirin and the other
journalists would appear from the
marksman's position 190 meters away
according to the model this is what the
marksmen would have seen when they began
shooting
the journalists press vests would have
been clearly visible
here and throughout the incident we were
able to verify their visibility by
placing a camera with a telephoto lens
at the precise position of the marksman
and taking a photograph at four times
magnification
indicating what the marksman would have
seen through the scope
the journalists were clearly
identifiable as such
we reconstructed ali's position when he
was shot and the bullet's point of
impact as well as shireen's position and
the point of impact when she was shot
and killed when the marksman shot
shireen she was turned away from them
with her press fest in full view we also
identified the impact of four shots that
hit this tree
the proximity of the shots confirms a
professional marksman repeatedly and
explicitly targeted the journalists
well let's bring in marwan bashara al
jazeera's senior political analyst he
joins us from london thank you very much
for being on the program
first of all i guess what's your
reaction to this report just how damning
is it
it's quite damning to be honest with you
i would have preferred
that this was not the truth
but clearly the facts
uh signal out that this is the truth of
what happened
it's sort of tragic but it's not
shocking
i have been saying that from the very
beginning
that it's very improbable to imagine
a journalist with a huge sign that says
i'm a press
wearing a vest
and a helmet
to be shot right between the helmet and
the vest
from far by our soldier who's hiding in
an armored vehicle this could only be a
targeted killing
there is no other way to explain it
other than
the most incredible of an
improbability so it's clear that
operationally speaking the israeli army
has given its soldiers a certain freedom
to act
and as we all know
the israeli military has been
radicalized over the last several
decades after 50 years of occupation
young israelis
and not so young israelis have been
radicalized in fact a lot of the people
in the israeli military are settlers
illegal settlers who serve in the
occupied territories
and a lot of those decisions are not
taken on some political level they are
operational decisions taken by someone
in command of that assassination unit
so i am not shocked
in fact i am pretty
you know assured of what we've known all
along but it's good to have the evidence
signaling more of the same underlining
what we thought all along
the investigation also ruled out the
possibility of uh confrontations
uh between israeli forces and
palestinian gunmen uh why do you think
that is significant
well i mean clearly from everything that
we've seen in terms of the shots being
shot
in terms of when and how in terms of the
time of the day
and this is the sort of a thing that the
new york times washington post bbc and
other cnn and other independent networks
have have affirmed and confirmed
that what the israelis tried to do in
the beginning was basically lie
because they do that you know occupation
forces tend to lie a lot in order to
prove their public relation image but
we've known
that under occupation occupation forces
tend to carry a lot of crimes but i
think a lot of us went along and tried
to really prove what is apparently clear
to a lot of us
and with all sorts of independent
investigations everyone realized that
the israelis basically threw their liar
out in order to confuse the public
opinion
but
what every investigation has shown
independent investigation including that
of today that is apparently very
technical
that it was shot by the israelis that it
was calm on the palestinian side that is
that the journalists were clearly marked
as journalists
and as i said
that it was clear that someone has
really tried to
target
a very vulnerable little space between
the head and the body between the helmet
and the vest
so clearly
whether the israeli soldiers whether he
acted
upon himself whether he was ordered by
his commander to shoot to kill
we don't know but that there is
a a a a an intentional killing of our
colleague
i think there is
little to no doubt about that at this
point in time
marwan bashar we are going to have to
leave it there that's our senior
political analyst from london thank you
well omar fawati is lead investigator on
shireen abu aglai's case for the
research group forensic architecture he
also joins us from london thank you very
much for being on this newshour can you
give us a sense of just how thorough
this investigation was what was the
scope of it
well we've been working every day since
the day that shireen was killed on 11th
of may on this
to create a very precise
forensic analysis of all circumstances
of the shooting
how thorough it is is that we
are creating for the first time a
spatial reconstruction and analysis
through footage and a photographic
documentation of the site that
transforms the site into a model that
can be measurable to the millimeter
with that with the unprecedented or
unseen before footage
we can locate the precise position of
the journalists including shirin about
throughout the incident of the shooting
at them as well as the position for the
first time to precisely tell you exactly
where the israeli occupation forces were
and where they shot out of we actually
know the hole that they shot out of by
by constructing this model and
positioning them throughout the space
we're able to ask questions about what
did the israeli soldier see when they
shot we were able to ask questions about
what was the timing of the shots were
there any others around these are
questions that were
coming up but we could not be answered
without this kind of forensic analysis
and what's different here is that our
work is
you know beyond the journalistic work
our work is admissible in in national
and international courts of law it will
be used to mobilize as evidence uh
legal actions for the justice of sharia
blanca so do you think that some of this
could play a part in the international
criminal court claim that has just gone
ahead this morning
we hope that
all our work including this one
is
giving evidence material and concrete
evidence that hasn't been given before
our list of findings is long and
thorough and precise and we do hope and
think that it will um
push us to to see for ourselves what we
knew all along that there was a
deliberate targeting that they could
identify them as journalists as they
were shooting uh that they denied
sharing
medical aid after she had been hit
and that there was no one else around
that there was no crossfire that there
was no fighting around i mean seeing
this evidence yes we do think uh that it
is um
beyond any doubt uh of what's happened
here not only of the possibility we know
that the israeli occupation forces shot
shooting and we have very strong
evidence to say that they deliberately
targeted them repeatedly
as journalists that they knew they were
journalists and they're repeatedly
targeting them so yes we think that it
will be a strong case for calling on
further investigations um
yeah we think it's very clear what we've
found here
omar ferwati we'll have to leave it
there you uh from the lead investigator
on the shireen abu ah clay
for the research group investigative
architecture from london thank you very
much for being on the program
thank you very much